Ramona Shelburne of the worldwide leader
NBA insider and senior writer for ESPN
espn.com back here on the Rich Eisen
show how was it Ramona I mean it was it
was cool my favorite I mean I just love
the fact that all these NBA luminaries
turned out right so like how Albany does
see Kareem abdul-jabbar sitting with
Bill Russell or Allen Iverson on the
court with his camera phone recording
everything I hate like Shaq deejaying
the party beforehand and Jeannie buzz
the owner of the Lakers like dancing in
the front row like waving her hands like
she just don't care I mean it's not
often you get a see like this like from
that that just purely from the spectacle
side from the basketball appreciation
side from the you know if you just love
sports like I mean who you couldn't help
but be tickled by it like a night by
that by a night like that you know I
mean do you think as he was going
through his career if I'd asked you told
you look you know obviously he was in
all-time great we saw it early on in his
career that when is that that that when
it was all over all of those luminaries
would show up for him
would you oh right I mean like I don't
think Kobe was beloved in his time like
he may be somebody who's remembered more
fondly by history than he was in his
time I mean the guy was very polarizing
when he played right you only won one
MVP everybody cool was criticized him
for taking too many shots or being
selfish or everyone say and obviously
you have the rape case in Colorado I
mean there was there was a there was a
lot of reasons why their people did not
like Kobe when he played and yet at the
end of it I think it was you know in a
lot of ways he owned a lot of that he
owned it he apologized the woman in
Colorado like I mean you go back now to
the history of what we're going through
I mean that you know you see you see
certain apologies the apology was was
pretty pretty strong right now it
doesn't forgive anything that happens
obviously we felt strong enough to file
charges but so you look at that and then
you know it is the way he played you
know he never apologized for taking that
many shots he's like no I really think
I'm the best often like this was my
mentality and I think
the fact that he just kind of owned who
he was what do you love him or hate him
I think that helps in terms of how
history is going to perceive you and he
you know I like a light a lot of a lot
of history historical figures how the
works kind of get lost to history
right and you remember the competitor
and you remember the great moments and
you know they showed some of those last
night at the game when they were
replaying everything it's pretty great
you know I mean he's all the game
winners and all the crazy Kobe things he
used to do like you know I had I was
here for most of them not not maybe
early Kobe it was still where he and I
are about the same age I was kind of in
high school in college for the early
years but but for those later years man
like it's 20 years of the same guy in
one town doing pretty incredible things
it was it was a great night yeah I mean
and I just remember you know when I was
on SportsCenter and doing SportsCenter
commercials with Stuart and him right
Ramona I mean it was back then the
reason why I bring it up is that was the
kid who waved Carl Malone off the blocks
in Madison Square Garden during the
all-star game and everybody was kind of
like who is this
you know this high school kid that
thinks he's so great that he waves the
mailman off the blocks during an
all-star game because he wanted to
isolate right and and and now there's
Bill Russell sitting next to Kareem and
they're all showing up for him it really
blew me away just seeing all those
visuals in a lot of ways he's great at
his own mythology right he has a
storytellers mind yes it he understood
that like you know we there's a there's
a whole talk about okay why did he
change his number and why did he pick 24
right and there's a lot of legend you
know series on that and you know the
popular one is always one more than
Michael Jordan's number okay yes you
needed a clean break you needed a that
was so number eight was never his number
right when he came into the league he
had always 132 but obviously that wasn't
an option with the Lakers that's magic
number so he had to like he had to
choose a new number and he was 24 and
like yeah we had him on you know we
talked to him yesterday and he said no
it's not the same with Mike it is that
there's 24 hours in the day and I wanted
it to
me that I should always be pursuing
greatness 24 hours in the day yeah I
don't know that's who we're not either
but the fact that he just came up with
that and like that's the way he says it
now and because because he really he did
back it up but we don't have any
evidence to the contrary all you ever
saw were workout videos of him it's 5:00
in the morning running sand dunes and
you know doing crazy totally things like
learning he taught himself to play piano
and he would post these videos at 3:00
in the morning of him learning how to
play moonlight sonata and later on he
told me he learned to play it for
Vanessa because you wanted to prove to
her how much he loved her and that was
kind of his way of getting her back
after everything that happened right and
I mean it's just like you have these
sort of mythological stories that like
now I just kind of smile because I know
the guy I'm like Nana so Kobe Kobe and
and I think the younger generation when
you talk to guys now they really
appreciated him they really appreciated
that competitive fire it was that
ability to sort of let it rip and not
not care if anybody said you're too
selfish you took too many shots like
he's like well I think I'm the best
option well in terms of that ask the
poll question of Roe Ramona Shelburne of
ESPN Brockman go for it yeah Ramona
who's the best high school two NBA
player of all time Kobe Kobe LeBron and
we added Kevin Garnett and Moses Malone
for good measure I mean part of me says
it's got to be Moses because he's the
original right like he's the guy that
made that okay and then Kevin I think
had a lot on his shoulders because there
was like a sort of modern-day version of
it and there was a lot to prove but God
I mean I I'm gonna probably I'm gonna
probably say LeBron just because he had
so much on his shoulders right from the
jump we just lived up to them I'm just
gonna turn it on because if that's the
first thing that pops into my head like
I don't think of I don't really think of
Kobe as a high school of NBA player
because he knows rookie here you don't
even you score at his first game right
key imagine if LeBron would not score in
his birthday we didn't even start for a
year and a half
I mean look III don't remember again
being on SportsCenter I mean Kobe got
drafted in the year that I arrived at
ESPN I do not recall getting ready to
watch SportsCenter and seeing Lower
Merion basketball games on here I don't
remember seeing that you know and and
and then when when Kobe was a free agent
I mean I remember what was about to be
and was thinking about going somewhere
else that was the only thing close to
the decision that we've ever seen right
now I do want to ask you
Ramona Shelburne here in the DirecTV 4k
NBA report here on the Rich Eisen show
we've or we can already determine so far
that the Lakers are on the right track
correct they're that they're that
they're arc is pointing up would you not
agree with that yeah I think you look
like they look like they're on the right
track but I don't know that I would say
that like they're there yet they've
license of it okay look I think Brandon
Ingram has taken a pretty big step
forward this year and he's a guy that
kind of you know he's a number two over
to number two overall pick in the draft
two years ago it's not like he didn't
have a lot of pressure on him but he
he's got a quiet personality and kind of
quiet game so he had a quiet rookie
season and it wasn't bad he wasn't good
some people sort of forgot about him but
I think he's he's taken a pretty big
step forward this year I think Lonzo if
you look at the last week lonzo's games
you he's starting to look like he's
figuring things out like he's getting to
the free-throw line a little more he's
being more aggressive he's actually
making some more of his shots is that
they look good in that sense and clearly
they've you know redone the front office
in a way that you could say that that's
heading in the right direction compared
to what you had before but they still
need to land like the guy like I mean
I've used so many Laker games this year
where like this young team is pretty
darn good but they don't have the guy at
the end who can close it out and like
the difference both times they play the
Warriors is that the Warriors have Kevin
Durant or Steph Curry like a first game
of a Steph Curry and he killed him in
the fourth quarter and overtime in
offenses last night it was Kevin Durant
like when you don't have that guy that
your team revolves around or that who
can deliver in the fourth quarter you
don't have anything yet
so who's the guy that wants to come I
mean let's we all know we all know that
LeBron everybody in this town thinks
he's he's gonna have no choice but to do
this because he's you know cuz it's the
Lakers I mean with LeBron I mean I you
know we we touched on that last week cuz
they played in Cleveland right so that
obviously was a good moment to talk
about it and you know I think the Lakers
still have a lot to prove to him because
they yeah they're going in the right
direction but are they like did that
current group they're not one player
away right like they need the guy but if
you're gonna like the Bron James at the
stages career he needs a team that's
ready to be the warrior just like he
needs whether that's in Cleveland or LA
or Houston or Philly like you you can't
just have a young team and hope that he
can lead them again like and I think
that the sense is you know if Paul
George would also come or if there's
another veteran who would also be you
know in that mix then then you got
something but I think the guy that you
still look at if all doors I mean that's
the that's you know Oklahoma City is
there they're kind of starting to trend
in positive direction but but Paul's LA
native and you still you know he didn't
ask to be in Oklahoma City I know he
sort of embraced the challenge of being
there this purpose he's made no promises
and you don't have any reason to believe
otherwise that he still looking at LA
and will have fun writing those stories
in about a week
Ramona thanks the call appreciate it
appreciate the T Center you got it
that's the Ramona Shelburne of ESPN the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience